- Hello, everyone.
Welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel, Firm Learning.
Today, I wanna talk about the
terrible events in Ukraine,
and how this affects consulting firms,
and especially the Russian business
of the consulting firms around the world.
After Russia invading Ukraine,
you see many organizations
around the world
who speak up and take
actions by, for instance,
stopping business in Russia.
Does this the case for the
consulting firms as well?
And what are maybe differences
among the different firms
in how they react to the Russian business?
And of course, what does this imply
for the employees working in
these Russian organizations?
So this is what I wanna talk
about today in this video.
I will donate all the YouTube ad revenue
that I receive from
this video to the UNHCR,
which is the UN agency mandated
to aid and protect
refugees around the world.
They're currently also active in Ukraine.
So if you watch the video,
it will directly contribute to that
if you watch the ads and
watch until the very end.
Thank you very much for
your support on this.
So in order to put together this video,
I did some desk research,
read lots of press statements,
also statements on LinkedIn
that many consulting firms
and the leaders of these firms published.
And I reached out to you on Instagram,
asking for your firsthand impressions,
firsthand insider knowledge,
on what is going on in
all these consulting firms
and what they're doing with
their Russian organizations.
So thanks so much for all the
messages that I did receive.
I do wanna say, as a disclaimer,
that first, the situation
is dynamically evolving.
So potentially the information
I'm sharing right now
is not accurate anymore
in a couple of days or a couple of weeks.
And second, because
lots of the information
I'm sharing in this video is
from you, from the community,
I have no direct way of verifying it.
Though if any of you proves me wrong,
that anything I say as
of today is not accurate
I will include a pinned post
in the comment section
with any clarifications
or any amendments or
corrections of what I'm saying.
So let's get started.
And first of all, I think it's fair to say
that the whole situation did leave a mark
on the consulting industry.
Lots of firms did take action
the moment we go firm by firm,
from any of the major firms,
what exactly they did.
There even was a statement
from Oleksandr Kravchenko
which was the managing
director of McKinsey in Ukraine
who released a post on LinkedIn saying
that the Russian actions
were a military crime.
So from my experience such
a candid political statement
is rather rare from leadership
of any big consulting firm.
As far as I know that
person who has uttered that
as a private person,
not necessarily as an official
spokesperson for the firm.
But still this reaction is remarkable,
and surely nothing like everyday business
what's going on right now.
But let's look into individual firms,
and let's start with the MBB
strategy consulting firms.
So McKinsey, BCG, and Bain.
Shortly after the news of the invasion,
McKinsey released a statement saying
that they will not any work
for the Russian government.
And then a couple of days later
they extended that to not
accepting any new work
for any Russian client whatsoever.
And rather similar
statements were released
by the leadership
of Boston Consulting Group and of Bain.
But what exactly does this mean
for the staff of these
organizations working in Russia?
And once again, I wanna reiterate that all
of this information was
collected from the community.
I wasn't able to verify any of it.
Feel free to leave a
comment if you know more.
And apparently for McKinsey, the situation
is that many colleagues got transferred
to the Kazakhstan office.
And from there, they
will conduct lion work
for especially middle Eastern clients,
but then also other
international projects.
And I know from at least
one instance where an offer
that a candidate received
during the interview process
was postponed by Boston Consulting Group.
They seemed to be in the middle
of the process of relocating
consultants to other offices.
So the process seemed to be more top down,
not necessarily only
focused on one office,
but more depending
on the individual situation
of the consultants.
And here I've been told that,
especially for some juniors
this process poses some issues.
So far it does not seem to
be clear what will happen
to the colleagues that will
not able to make this switch
to make this transition to another office.
Bain seems to have transferred a good part
of their consultants to the Dubai office,
and then helping them to get staff
to international projects,
also projects in the middle east.
As with the other firms
there seems to be an ongoing process
but I have been told by
sources from all of these firms
that so far there was no
layoff directly related
to the situation in Ukraine.
Next is Oliver Wyman.
And while the Oliver
Wyman leadership stated
that they don't want to conduct
any more client work in Russia,
there was a press release
from Marsh McLennan
which is the company
that owns Oliver Wyman
that said, we intend to transfer ownership
of our Russian businesses
to local management who
will operate independently
in the Russian market.
So what this means is,
and I got this confirmed
from some local sources,
that what apparently they're trying to do
is that they're asking the partners,
the local partners in Russia,
to buy out the Russian
organization of Oliver Wyman
and then potentially continue operating it
under a different name.
Now in this video, I don't
want judge these actions.
I trust this might be good
news to the Russian employees
as maybe likely they
will not lose their job
or might not need to move
to other countries, other
regions, other offices.
I also understand, though,
that all far there's no definite
agreement on this matter.
Similar to the others, currently
also released a statement
that they want to stop any
work for Russian clients
but do want to keep
the offices still open.
So far was frankly not able to collect
any insider information
from any Russian employee
currently right now.
So if you have anything to share on that,
please leave a comment
in the comment section.
Next is Roland Berger.
They have very much aligned
with the other companies.
So they're stopping any
client activities in Russia.
To my knowledge, leaving
the offices open for now.
They're now relocating colleagues
mainly to the middle east
and also some other international offices
and helping them to get staff
to international projects from there.
Accenture arguably took
the most drastic measures
from the companies on this list.
They completely discontinued
all operations in Russia
and laid off all of their
apparently 2,300 people
working in that country.
Overall, the whole
organization was laid off
and the severance offer
that these people received,
this at least what I was told,
is that they got three monthly salaries
as a severance payment.
Let's next talk about the Big 4.
So this is PWC, KPMG, EY, and Deloitte.
What's first important to understand is
when we talk about the Big 4 firms,
that due to legal regulations,
also due to their audit business,
they are structured in local,
legally independent subsidiaries.
So there is a legal entity
for the Russian business for
each of these four companies.
And what all of these four firms announced
is that they want to stop the affiliation
of the Russian entity
from the global network
of any these four firms.
So what this means
is that the entity that was,
for instance, called PWC Russia
in the future cannot
call itself PWC anymore.
But that entity still exists
and can still continue its operation.
And I trust this is what is happening
for all the four Big 4 companies.
So in all fairness,
given that these are
legally independent entities
it probably was more or less difficult,
maybe even impossible
for the mother organization to completely
stop the operations in this country.
Of course, I'm not a legal
expert on these issues.
The result surely is that these entities
will continue its operations
likely under a new name in the future.
And I received some details
from an internal memo
of one of these Russian organizations
from one of these firms.
And in this memo,
Russian leadership stated
that they actually see the
situation from now on positively
because now there will be less competition
from international firms.
And on top, they will
also get access to lots
of talent from other consulting firms,
staff that was laid off
or did not want to relocate
to any other location.
Those of course are people who will likely
maybe want to work for any
of these firms going forward.
So, interesting situation.
Let me know what you think
about this in the comments.
Hope this served as an
informative overview
of the situation of
consulting firms in Russia.
If you took any value out of this video,
as always destroy the like
button for the YouTube algorithm.
And also subscribe to stay
up to date on my content.
Big, big thanks
to the members of this
channel supporting my work.
Once again, I will donate all
ad revenue from this video
the UN refugee agency.
My name is Heinrich.
I release weekly videos every Saturday.
Thank you all for watching.
Until next week, and goodbye.